hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the
introduction to his short work on
Liberty John Stuart Mill is going to
tell us the basis on which he's going to
argue and so in his own words he says
it's proper to state I forego any
advantage which could be derived to my
argument from the idea of abstract right
as a thing independent of utility what
does he mean by utility he says it's the
ultimate appeal on all ethical questions
utility is the sort of preponderance of
good outcomes over bad outcomes
generally understood by utilitarians
which Mill is the second generation
instance of in terms of pains and
pleasures but it could be understood in
terms of benefits and harms more broadly
and he tells us that I regard utility is
the ultimate appeal on all ethical
questions as a utilitarian
but it must be utility in the largest
sense grounded on the permanent
interests of man as a progressive being
what is a progressive being a being who
develops so this is also tied in with a
notion of proper human development as
well so he's not going to make an appeal
to simply de ontological or abstract
principles of right instead he is going
to try to show that it's useful to apply
what he's going to do you know formulate
in this working which is often called
the harm principle and that in in
respect of freedom of opinion that it
should allow the widest dissemination of
opinions their expression their
publication so long as they are not
directly causing harm so you know if you
were to say you know we should commit
genocide and here's exactly how we ought
to do it and let's go do it right now
here's the plans for it I think mill
would say well now you've crossed
certain lines and the state can have an
interest in regulating that but in
general Mill is saying we ought to
tolerate as much diversity of opinion as
possible especially on controversial
matters now why why is it useful to do
that isn't it better just to have the
truth and know what that is and not be
burdened with having to hear about all
sorts of other things which might be
complete nonsense or might you know be
offensive to you or irritate you or just
might not actually be true wouldn't it
be better just to have like you know one
book that contains all the answers and
that's it
Mill says no no that's not good for
human beings it's not good for us as the
kind of beings that we are in part
because we are truth seeking beings
truth is part of our you know good state
so how can considering ideas that we
think might be false or might be
dangerous or might be noxious how can
that actually be helpful for us so
there's several main things that he
discusses in this chapter several main
arguments that he's making and he sums
them up at the end I'm presenting them
here a little bit out of order from his
reformulations of them because I'm
sticking to the order in which he
presents them in the chapter so the
first thing he says is that the opinion
that's being silenced or repressed might
actually be true and so you know if
is in fact true and we are repressing
the truth well that's a problem for us
because now we don't have any way of
arriving at the truth so he says that
you know to deny this is to assume our
own infallibility we'll come back to
that in just a moment then he also
points out a certain you know usefulness
as well - false opinions this might seem
a little paradoxical how can something
that's false actually be useful for us
as human beings well not directly so
it's not useful for us to believe things
that are false but if we happen to
believe the truth we can believe the
truth in multiple kinds of ways we can
believe the truth because we stumbled
across it and you know somebody told it
to us and that's the only thing that
we've ever encountered before so we just
accepted on faith and never think about
anything else and mil says that's not
really a rational way of understanding
truth right you're you're not using your
mind you're basically just using your
Faculty of parroting back things you're
not you're not developing yourself so
holding an opinion on rational grounds
is very important for him and he frames
it like this even if the received
opinion be not only true that's the
opinion that you hold but the whole
truth unless it is suffered to be and
actually is vigorously and earnestly
contested it will buy most of those who
receive it be held in the manner of a
prejudice with little comprehension or
feeling of it's rational grounds so if
you know you're thinking in terms of
religion if you're living in a country
that follows the old adage you know
about whoever's ruling gets to decide
what the religion is and everyone else
has to stick with that and nothing else
can be taught you're going to hold that
on the basis essentially of a prejudice
not of a reasoned opinion that was able
to absorb the brunt and an answer back
polemical interlocutors and that's
that's very important according to John
Stuart Mill we can say similar things
about lifestyles the only way that you
were brought up was that you know men
dress this way and women dress this way
and men drive the trucks of women stay
behind and you know tend to the oven and
things like that and and you're never
exposed to any contradictory opinions
and never actually consider that the
possibility of them being true even if
that were to be true which I highly
doubt that you know these gender roles
ought to be observed like that you would
be holding it on the basis of mere
prejudice mere convention you wouldn't
have any good reasons and that's part of
what it means to be a rational being and
hold rational convictions you wouldn't
have any good reasons for the position
that you take or if you did have any
reasons you could bring up it would be
sort of on the basis of a catechism that
you were provided and those reasons
would probably be as weak as the ideas
themselves that you're endorsing so it's
important to actually have a clash and
to hear other points of view so that you
can then defend your own point of view
if you haven't defended your own point
of view mill would say there's something
a little sketchy going on there's
another interesting thing that he points
out as well that has generated a useful
feature of having falsehoods out there
bouncing around he says that the meaning
of the doctrine itself whatever it is
that you happen to believe in will and
be will be in danger of being lost or
enfeebled and deprived of its vital
effect on the character and conduct the
dogma becoming a mere formal profession
inefficacious for good but come burring
the ground and preventing the growth of
any real and heartfelt conviction from
reason or personal experience very nice
prose there on Mills part what's the
point
again if you're only accepting opinions
because they're the ones that are out
there and that's what you you know
you're supposed to believe and you don't
have other opinions that may be false to
contest them
it's going to have much less influence
on your your life and this is very
important both in practical issues and
in theoretical matters as well you might
think for example about you know some of
the Christological debates that went on
in early Christianity and were felt to
be of incredible importance by many
people so much so that they would fight
and you know anathematized each other
and you know now look at you know people
today and say are these really issues
for for most of us now some of them are
most of them I think most Christians
have only the dimmest connection to them
whatsoever right it's when you have to
defend the point of view that you have
that you can actually live it out in any
sort of meaningful way and we could say
this not just about religious doctrines
but philosophical doctrines political
doctrines lifestyle matters all sorts of
commitments ethical ideas any of those
sorts of things there's a danger of a de
generating into mere lip service when we
don't have a contestation going on the
third argument that mill is providing
and this is quite a good one is that
there's a danger of what he calls
one-sidedness in the doctrines that we
hold so if we rule out other opinions we
we are setting ourselves up for problems
because the other opinion might not be
completely true but it might as he says
be an error but also contain a portion
of truth and since the general or
prevailing opinion on any subject is
rarely or never the whole truth it's
only by the collision of adverse
opinions that the remainder of the truth
has any chance of being accepted so if
we rule out other points of view and we
sow it has already been decided this is
right all that's wrong well there's
probably grains of truth in that stuff
that we've dismissed as wrong and and
that will supply
or remedy the lakhs within the point of
view that we have ourselves and you know
it you could if we want to use a
metaphor that Mill is not using here we
could say that you know bodies of truth
are healthier the more that instead of
setting up you know impermeable
boundaries they're able to let in some
other stuff from the outside and take it
in and assimilate it and make it part of
its structure and this is indeed how
healthy traditions of inquiry do in fact
function so these are some of Mills main
reasons for saying that we really do
need to be you know you could say
open-minded to the extent of hearing
other doctrines and hearing them
presented in their their you know best
ways not distorting them not so that we
necessarily accept all of them or waver
between them but so that we actually do
arrive at the truth and he says that
there's you know two main things that we
have to worry about here and this is
similar to what William James says in in
other places that you know we we have
the opportunity missing out on a truth
that we want to know and we also don't
eliminate error in what it is that we
believe by by doing that there's two
problems that we could fall into so Mill
is making a very you know strong
argument here on the basis of utility
usefulness to us as human beings for
considering a wide range of opinions and
thereby allowing freedom of expression
you